of
real muscle yeah now i want you to
manipulate my endocrines
okay so i go i have i have six months
okay and i want
10 pounds of real muscle i want legs
that i want my jeans my quads to have
problems
in yeah i want to have a problem now we
can't do that i want to go buy new jeans
yeah okay um so i want mini i want to
look as close
i'm never going to reach you but at
least you don't look like brad pitt i
want that
i want that form brad pitt and fight
club yeah
but actually that's the way i always
advocate to people is is
them i'll start off with the mistakes
that i see people make i want to get big
i'm doing a bro split where i'm hitting
chest on mondays
arms on tuesdays hamstrings on thursdays
it's like hell yeah you're spreading it
out too much
what i would do is if you were trying if
you have six months you want to get as
big as possible
do everything every day but the minimal
like do heavy as [ __ ] shoulder press
heavy bench press heavy like if you
could squat every day or dead lift every
day but just a few intense sets right
like high intensity low volume and
repeat that
it's it's sort of some people there's
body builders out there who do
a full body five days a week wow but for
legs one day all they're doing is
five sets of lunges okay so because when
you do a leg day for two hours
by the time you get to the third
exercise how much fun do you have in the
tank
right so i would rather go in and go i'm
gonna do for example like
there were years where i'd just do two
intense sets of squats any time i did a
leg day
for for my quads at least you do one set
to failure at 10 and then one set to
failure at 20.
have you ever done a 20 set barbell
squat to failure
it's nightmare absolutely right yeah so
that
you don't need a lot of weight well it
would be as heavy as you can for 20. so
that would be you would figure out that
percentage
right but it isn't you're not it's not a
triple right so
if you do the compound movements because
an overhead press versus a lateral raise
like
you could say i'm going in and doing 10
sets me and chappelle did we we did the
sets
leading up to the max lifts we did like
you know my five places you did 425 and
rented at 600 yeah the 425 is right
there by the way just in case of you yes
we're gonna watch that
but then after that we did four sets of
deficit deadlifts on a
timer and we were wiped after that so it
doesn't like that four sets of deadlifts
is going to have as much you know when
you talk about manipulating your
endocrine system
that's going to have as much impact as
25 sets of
lighter workouts okay so you're an
advocate of heavy weight
low volume high intensity as heavy as
you can to the compound movements
because that gives you
95 percent of your results if you're
just trying to shock your body into
being
different yeah and also a caloric
surplus because that's a the you know
now i gotta eat yeah feed
you gotta feed and and you know
they have a child we gotta feed you got
that now i'm not a big eater
that's the problem i'm going to stay i'm
i'm going to stay a coat hanger
well that's also something i think you
could figure like people come to me
i know it works on the opposite end too
like for when people are trying to lose
weight
like but i don't want to eat chicken
well you don't have to you can eat the
foods you like in the right proportions
and i would say like is there anything
you like to eat like steak or
like something where i go i don't
believe in going
you have to eat this if you like
something can we crank that up and get
you in a position maybe maybe
shakes yeah right shakes is a very easy
way to be like oh
like people would be like i can't get
the 200 grams of protein today i'm like
you can't [ __ ] make a shake before
you go to bed
the problem with all of this is i'm a 54
year old guy trying to put on ten pounds
right that's the real thing he's like
okay but it's possible yeah
right mark absolutely nothing go ahead
mark answer
okay
i gotta run some gear the other thing is
even that question is in the context of
like
i've heard that this guy did that for
this role it's
all [ __ ] [ __ ] oh dude it's all
[ __ ] yeah but they say i ain't
chicken and broccoli rice and i didn't
know
you didn't you were juicing yeah
the most powerful injectable anabolic
steroids not free like
like you know what they like not for
anybody not for humans
um so hey
before he goes on should mark start his
own [ __ ] podcast i told him i'd
produce this guy he's
yes we already have another don't give
out the name don't give out any name
yeah but we have a name concept he
crushes it cause there's no one else
uh dalia text me goes hey uh you cool
you're getting shaped man you're on the
road and stuff
uh your friend that looks like a street
fighter 2 character who is that
[Laughter]
just call it tits for days i just want
to finish that thought because anybody
listening who thinks like
to me it's criminal because these people
are trying to tell you something chris
hemsworth's like
oh it was his body devil had some
article in muscle and fitness and he's
like
yeah i got down to 5 body fat while
gaining 20 pounds of
that's impossible even on steroids you
didn't gain 20 pounds of muscle
while dropping the five percent body fat
the picture you're showing isn't view at
five percent body fat it's
nine percent body fat and then the
funneling into the workout app where
you're doing like body weight lunges and
flipping like that's not how you built
the muscle either so
everything about it is a lie and the
hollywood thing with whatever celebrity
you can think of who's done a
transformation recently
for a role whether it's zac efron or
camille non-johnny
they can't say it out loud no they're
not wait they're not allowed to say it
out now no cause i was wondering i was
like why don't people
just say it because think how many kids
yeah
but it's also like this you've had mr
olympia on the show and it was like tr
we're trying to teeter on
he's like you know i take muscle text
like you said yeah yeah it's the most
it was this yeah phil heath yeah we were
like remember we had them on years ago
it's like you want to be like what are
you running anybody selling
supplements you can't talk about it
anybody who's got a sponsored clothing
line
can't talk about it yeah independent
youtuber or something
there's certain pockets of people who
can be open and honest about what they
do but for the most part there's 18
different disincentives
yeah but is it because a lot of the but
is it because a lot of this stuff is
illegal or something or what like it's
it's crowded it's like this weird dark i
don't know because
it's like this weird dark cloud where
doesn't it i'm sure i'm sure you get
this mark like the
only reason you're big in shape because
you're on steroids yeah it's like do
take the exact same stuff i take it
right let me know how it works out for
me
yeah what's interesting is you can look
at that yeah like it's like dude first
of all
the bodybuilders you see like how do you
think phil heath looked before he took
steroids
like he took steroids you know he
because his muscle insertions
duncan he was five hey duncan they call
them the gifts
they call mr genesis crazy you wouldn't
get into professional bodybuilding
unless you
people were like holy [ __ ] unless your
base was pretty [ __ ] wrong you know
right but if you look at for example
there's various powerlifting federations
and
cat you're probably familiar with this
right like the tested versus non-tested
yeah
the difference between tested and
non-tested um
federations isn't that much you think
like the guys on steroids are squatting
two thousand pounds no it's like
fifteen percent more sometimes not even
because
like am i built to have a thousand
pounds on my back and squat it will snap
me in half yeah
certain freak individuals are just doing
that
like you know and at that level there's
just it's not as much as you'd think
because ultimately
like the tendon strength and the
the density of your bones is the
limiting factor whether i can bench
press 700 pounds
what would you what would you weigh i
mean you're a big guy what would you
weigh
if you didn't lift weights i mean
probably
160. no you still be in the 200s right
yeah
i eat a lot yeah i'm i'm large and i i
always had a big
appetite yeah so that was like that's
the main thing when you talk about i
don't eat a lot it's like that that's
never been the issue for me so that's
part of the specific about your diet
when i'm cutting yeah but now i kind of
just go like
if i'm if if i eat the protein goal
every day then everything else kind of
falls in place because you're so
full you know what i mean or like i mean
i could eat more but then also i just
have like certain things in my house or
i'm like i'm having the choice of eating
this or that
but it's confined to relatively healthy
foods right but you do a lot of cardio
too to like
i also do hill runs every day yeah yeah
yeah the kids got
legs yeah your podcast you should do
them in those
70s short shorts right you're one of
those boy ones i gave you yeah if your
dick popped up
about the front oh it pops out yeah it's
a dick on them too